and fighting has intensified in the
southeast of the country in recent days
with officials in the city of mariopol
reporting almost 12 000 fatalities
despite that there continues to be
reports of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
stalling so what is the um latest on the
ground the founder and commander of the
Georgian National Legion of the
Ukrainian Army
joins me now and this is quite
interesting because the Georgian Legion
is like a Foreign Legion isn't it how
important are overseas fighters to the
Ukrainian military
you know Georgian Legion is one of the
first uh uh group of foreigners who ever
joined Ukrainian Army so
um the motivation of Georgian Legion is
you know to help Ukrainian go through
the same experience what Georgia has
already had in your uh during Russian
agents so you know for ukrainians it is
very important to see uh among them
people that support them and to see
different nationalities who are standing
with them physically and holding on the
fire you know we've been doing this job
for eight years and Ukraine generally
has been talking about facing Russian
army for eight years and unfortunately
the world just started to speak that
Ukraine has been invited by Russia
Ukraine has been invaded by Russia eight
years ago
yeah and on the point of overseas
Fighters mamouka how many overseas
foreign Fighters do you have uh fighting
at the moment do you think
there are I would not you know say the
number or there are a lot of guys that
are joining still joining us from UK
from United States mostly from United
Kingdom uh in my opinion those guys are
the last heroes that are standing now
and physically defending the freedom of
a free Nation
how many do you think you have from the
UK is it possible to say
in our uh requests that we received
there are more than 300. so we are uh
they are coming uh uh with small groups
they're joining us they're doing a good
job they are professionals soldiers and
they're sharing their experience with us
and with Ukrainian Army also
and and does that 300 does that include
the four serving British soldiers who
have apparently come here soldiers who
are still in the Army in the in the UK
uh men who are now on an active duty
cannot get into Georgian Legion we
refused A young guy who tried to do that
we bought a ticket and sent him back to
UK because it would cause a problem to a
young man who probably does not
understand it but I appreciate the guy
who gave up everything and came to help
Ukraine we explained him that it is not
a time now to uh give up his life and
come here because he's on an active duty
and we do not accept uh soldiers who are
on an active duty in any country not
only in UK
okay and I think they're wanted back in
the UK anyway do you want more volunteer
fighters to come uh from the UK would
you like to see more coming over now you
know I want more people to really
understand what is happening today in
Ukraine of course we want to uh uh
everybody who wants to defend Freedom we
want all of them to be here and stand
with us
thank you
and what sort of fighting are the the
fighters from the UK the volunteers
involved in are they are they fighting
at the moment where are they in Ukraine
can you tell me
oh I cannot tell the location
unfortunately they're doing the same
missions that Georgian Legion has been
doing during these eight years uh we
have special groups and uh uh we are
doing our military specifics
unfortunately I cannot say everything on
camera
and can you tell me whether any have
been
um killed in action or injured in action
can you tell me that
we had recently injured one Georgian
Soldier we have not had any casualties
fortunately and I hope uh we will not
have in a future
and mamuka how much difference do these
foreign Fighters how much difference do
they make to the Ukrainian military
it is more more more moral difference
because when ukrainians see the guys are
joining and standing with them it plays
a really good role you know uh to hire
their morale
and just more broadly uh mamuka what do
you think the state of players in this
War I mean can the ukrainians continue
the resistance that they're showing at
the moment
I think ukrainians can continue
resistance Russians cannot continue it
the weak point that I've been talking
about always its Open Sky about Ukraine
uh terroristic regime of Putin is uh
shelling uh kindergartens he's shelling
uh children hospitals and they're
targeting uh populated areas to cause
the panic in the country
thank you very much for being with us
very interesting thank you thank you